et depuis hier on a appris l'arrivée
prochaine de l'émission carte poule car
ok alors est ce une bonne ou une
mauvaise idée
c'est l'heure d'une nouvelle enquête de
baba c'est pas lui c'est calme il karl
combal plus connu sous le nom de camille
combal
après avoir surveillé la télévision avec
succès pendant neuf ans l'ancien
saltimbanque de ses huit s'est dit il
faut que je me chauffe voilà déjà six
semaines que le trublion de tf1 à nîmes
danse avec les stars aux côtés de celles
dont on n'a plus le droit de prononcer
le nom et qu'on appellera donc karine se
raconte en plus d'animer cette émission
où des gens qu'on ne connaît pas à fond
du tam-tam que qu on a appris hier soir
que le bel étalon allait être aux
commandes de l'adaptation du concept
américain car poule
karaoke programme dans lequel jamais ce
corps d'un fait chanter des stars telles
que la digue à sia ou encore justin
bierber un format similaire existe cinq
gangs in the car adapté hier soir dans
touche pas à mon poste par cyril hanouna
ce fut un four cette séquence a
immédiatement rejoint le cimetière de
l'adar cas aux côtés du 20 heures 20
heures de love story ou encore de la
météo de bertrand chamerois vous l'avez
compris chanter dans une voiture et deux
bons tons alors l'adaptation de cartes
poule karaoké par camille combal est
elle une bonne ou une mauvaise idée
les stars internationales clément rien
et terence tel trouveront-elles le temps
de venir chanter avec lui malgré leur
agenda surchargé et surtout après avoir
participé à the voice kid
aurons nous la chance de découvrir en
voiture mohamed benyamna plus connu sous
le nom de bouder autant de questions
auxquelles l'inspecteur baba pas tenté
de répondre
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
l'heure pour vous fassiez une idée
honnête vidéo qui vous explique le
concept car pour le karaoké regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
justin ex doux à pau
pas
[Musique]
alors est ce que vous y croyez ou pas
donc voilà alors on sait pas où ça va
être alors il ya quatre possibilités
je vous le dis quatre possibilités sait
où ce sera à la place de c'est canteloup
sur tf1 pendant des salves voilà parce
que ce sera 5 à 6 minutes ou bien à
l'intérieur d'un nouveau prime de
camille sur tf1 voilà à la place de
vendredi tout est permis au deuxième
partie de soirée sur tf1 la place de
vendredi tout est permis ou bien un
prime sur tmc août et fx c'est ça ou
bien sûr quotidien ma fenêtre en faire
une pastille dans les forêts gagnent
barthez voilà non mais c'est vrai voilà
eric samyn gumi était intéressé
apparemment la boîte de production de
laine barthès est intéressé par le
format mais voilà ça c'est vraiment
c'est une hypothèse
alors on va les réveiller la seule bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'ils ont compris qu'ils
peuvent pas en faire une vraie émission
7 parce que chez dams cordelle c'est une
pastille c'est simplement un petit truc
qui dure 4 5 minutes pas plus
et par ailleurs nous on a un souci en
france c'est que vous avez vu les stars
annoncées beyoncé c'est michelle obama
c'est oui alors moi j'ai cas moi j'ai
pas d'ailés benhaim dans une voiture non
mais voilà tout de suite secondes et on
descend un tout petit peu d'un cran
alors oui qu'est-ce qui se passe non je
pense que vraiment ri alors alors obama
préfère à face cap 30 me camille
franchement âgées un conseil même si je
respecte beaucoup
cyril hanouna qui gear a fait un
désastre before le ba-ba car c'était
épouvantable
donc donc c'était raté et je sais que
c'est un génie créé un bien brillantes
animateurs mais ne va pas là dedans ça
va être une catastrophe parce que c'est
pas qui tuera comme chanteur mais si on
n'y a pas un lebel vraiment énorme
ça va être épouvantable abstiens toi moi
je pense que si c'est bien fait ça peut
être bien hier on l'a loupé mais ça peut
être maxime chupin mathieu de
l'emballage c'est un type de l'accord ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est en enduro
effectivement aux etats-unis ces cinq
minutes dans un light show ces cinq
minutes vous avez vu qu'ils ont elton
john les derniers
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là là je le redis avec du charisme et
donc frais la bonne personne pour le
faire mais effectivement j'y crois pas
parce que si c'est pour avoir un
chanteur français un peu moins bien à
côté ça ne marchera pas et en revanche
ce n'est pas tf1 qui a les droits c'est
l'associé de camille combal dit qu'on
allait beaucoup ici producteur a bâti
les drôles de dire quelque chose non sur
le papier c'est très excitant
effectivement ces jeunes c'est qls et
moderne et on adore évidemment quand on
regarde ça sur civière après moi je
trouve que d'abord c'est malin de la
part de tf1 parce que c'est un
aspirateur à jeunes aujourd'hui les
jeunes consomment des programmes courts
type youtube heures et effectivement ces
quatre minutes là tout le monde le
regarde c'est complètement virale je
pense qu'effectivement cani serait très
bien la dormeuse les enfants n'ont pas
très bien en revanche qui présentait le
programme
oui s'il n'a pas ce côté camille combal
un peu potache genre le garçon qui est
là mais qui ose pas vraiment un peu
timide il fait pas l'invitée du volant
et la chanson vraiment il va vraiment
chante vraiment il assume donc je sais
pas c'est camille combal sera très à
l'aise aussi dans cet état là des
extraits les plus forts de carpes ou le
karaoké c'est la prestation d'adèle dans
la voiture ah ouais de james corden
regardez ils ont des passés ensemble et
180 modèles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]